Speaker 1: So for this week's COVID update,
we usually do this Tuesday or Wednesday,
I actually do not have news for you that daily
cases have continued down in the United States
for weeks and weeks and weeks, really since the
start of September. I've been telling you weekly.
Hey, guys, good news. U.S. cases are declining
all the way down last week to cases being down
59 percent from the peak during the Delta wave,
but sadly this week over the last week, cases
are still down relative to that delta peak. But
no more than they were last week, they basically
flattened. We're down 59 percent from the Delta
Peak to be exact. Average daily cases in the U.S.
are now down fifty nine point nine nine percent.
So like basically 60 percent, not a big change
from last week's number of 59 percent. So for
whatever reason, and we'll talk about maybe why
cases have leveled off a bit in the United
States now 60000, if we're declining, 60000
is, you know, better than 100000, better than
160000 where we were at the peak of the delta with
as an endemic flat level. If cases are going to
steady, you know, steady at 60000. That's not
going to cut it for getting back to what we would
call normal. It's just way too high a level. The
good news is that deaths have continued down over
the last week, maybe not surprisingly, because
deaths tend to lag cases on about a three to four
week delay. Deaths in the U.S. now down about 45
percent from their Delta Peak, which was close
to 2000. Now we're seeing about 1050 1100 COVID
deaths per day in the United States. About a third
of where we were at the very worst peak in January
of 2021. But way, way too high to be anywhere
near what we would call a normal situation.
Remember that in a typical flu season, US COVID
deaths? I'm sorry. U.S. flu deaths average about
100 a day over the course of the year, so we
are still seeing 10 to 11 times the daily deaths
from COVID than from flu in a typical season.
Now what's happening around the world? Last week,
we actually saw cases tick up globally a little
bit, and we wondered, Is it a trend or is it a
blip? Sadly, globally, cases have again ticked
up just a little bit. Not by much. Basically,
steady last week we were seeing about four hundred
and twenty thousand cases of COVID per day. We're
now seeing about four hundred and 25000 cases of
COVID per day. Not a big change, but not a good
number. We've also seen global deaths kind of
level out slightly tick up, not a major change.
Right now, about 7000 people every day around the
world are dying of COVID. The big news in the U.S.
over the last few days is that a CDC panel has
unanimously recommended that the Pfizer COVID
vaccine be approved for kids ages five to 11.
That's a major step in starting to vaccinate kids
five to 11. That would be a major step forward
in better protecting people. There is the belief
that maybe as soon as this Friday, the day after
tomorrow, five to 11 year olds could start to
get vaccinated. We don't yet know how many parents
plan to get there five to 11 year olds vaccinated.
That's a question. It's an empirical question to
which we don't yet have an answer. We do know that
is going to be a different dosage. The dosage for
five to 11 year olds is going to be about a third
of what it would be for adults. And importantly,
you may have read you may not the way that these
doses are distributed for adults and 12 plus year
olds is in vials that contain multiple vaccines.
At one point it was five with sort of a little
extra. There was approval for a 10 dose vial,
and you fill the syringe with the appropriate
amount from what is being said so far in order
to avoid any confusion. Not only is the
dose one third for five to 11 year olds,
but the vials will be different. Just so there's
no confusion whatsoever about from this is
the adult vial and you take X amount. You will
have a different sized vial differently labeled
when it's for the five to 11 year old. So not
only do you put a different amount in. A syringe,
but it will be coming out of a different vial,
all meant to reduce confusion. So that's going on
the other news that a few of you sent me, which
I don't think there's really any reason to panic
right now. It doesn't sound good. The headline
is that there's a potentially faster spreading
Delta variant a y 4.2, which has now been
spotted in eight states before people flip out.
It is believed that a Force 4.2 spreads faster
than the main Delta variant, but there is no
evidence at this time that it causes more severe
illness. Vaccines remain effective against the Air
Force two variant, and in addition to that, it
is not. There is no evidence at this time that
it is going to become a dominant variant anyway to
sublineage it staying as a very small fraction of
circulating cases. And it's been around for
weeks, but it is being studied at sort of a
descendant of the Delta variant. I may get my
third dose this weekend. A Netherlands recently
announced everyone will be able to get third
doses, including people under 60. I spoke to my
doctor about it. My doctor said. Right now, it's
not something where I'm saying to you, sir. That's
how my doctor talks to me. He says, Sir. He's not
saying, sir. Go and get the third dose for sure.
But if you get it, it's fine. There's no downside.
I was vaccinated with my second dose at the end of
February, which which it's been, what, almost
nine months at this point since my second dose.
So I'm looking very strongly at getting my
third dose this week. And let's put it that way,
that's the latest on COVID. We'll see
what happens between now and next week.